Ciao Maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo videooo.
Uomini aprite le orecchie è arrivato il momento di prendere nota una volta per tutte perché
queste sono le frasi che non ci dovete mai dire e ve le dovete ricordare
sai qual è il problema
sei troppo perfetta
secondo me; meriti di meglio. fidati!
è sì forse hai ragione
merito di meglio
merito di meglio di un cretino
come te che dice una frase del genere, si perché di tutte le frasi che puoi dire per
scaricarmi cioè meriti di meglio è proprio la peggiore
chi era quella? eh chi era qu.. perché non mi dici (oh rilassati)
dove l'hai conosciuta e in quale serata sei stato con lei e non me l'hai detto?
non mi calmo, (calmati) non mi calmo (respira, respira). IO NON RESPIRO E IO NON MI CALMO, tu mi devi delle spiegazioni; è una questione di rispetto (aspetta, aspetta... hai il ciclo vero??)
e allora amore mio cucciolo se vuoi che mi rilassi
non me lo dire non mi dire che mi devo rilassare che mi devo calmare perché otterrai solamente l'effetto contrario ma non è finita qui
perché l'apice si raggiunge quando lui ti guarda e ti dice:
(facciamo una cosa, ne riparliamo quando ti calmi. ok?)
bravo, bravo. vai via
bravo eviti sempre discutere perché non te ne frega niente che io sto male non te ne frega niente.
hai lasciato la tua ragazza
li incazzata, da sola, senza aver chiarito; ma la cosa fantastica è che la colpa è la tua
bravo sei molto intelligente!
ciao amore, ma questi chiletti mangiato in sti giorni? cene e feste!!
cioccolato
allora ormai è risaputo si sa che noi donne siamo fissate con la linea e con il peso
ecco voi uomini non lo sapete a quanto pare cosa non vi è chiaro che già siamo in paranoia e ci guardiamo allo specchio
e non ci piacciamo è l'ultima cosa che vogliamo sentirci dire dal nostro ragazzo dal nostro compagno da quello con cui usciamo é
sei ingrassata cosa vi chiaro? non ce lo potete dire no no no
(Quindi che vuoi fare) ma non lo so.
Non sai mai nulla mai una volta che prendi una decisione
Io non prendo mai una decisione. io?! io?!
tu invece? dimmi una volta in cui hai preso tu l'iniziativa. una volta in cui hai scelto tu il
ristorante hai scelto tu dove andare in vacanza ho sempre fatto tutto io per una volta che non mi viene in mente niente
stai zitto!!
(ma perché ti metti tutto sto trucco? stai meglio senza)
cioè con tutti i soldi che spendo in trucchi dopo aver passato due ore per farmi questo make up
stratosferico tu con una frase del genere rovini tutto noi donne ci trucchiamo per per sentirci bene
con noi stesse per per piacere a noi non a voi
cretini che neanche vi rendete conto se una è truccata bene se una é struccata se una c'ha un brufolo eh dai
Che figa la tua amica! quale? quella con le tette grandi.
fa vedere. no vabbè ma la segui pure, mi fai schifo. (non smettere di seguirla). pubblica delle foto interessanti
che schifo
senti coso allora già mi dà fastidio che seguì 400 fighe su instagram sconosciute se poi ti metti pure a fare apprezzamenti
su una delle mie migliori amiche, prima di tutto non è più mia amica...
Amoree! guarda. (che cosa?), come cosa? non vedi, non si vede?
no non noto nulla
cioè ho appena litigato col parrucchiere perché lui voleva tagliarmi i capelli di 3 cm
e io gli ho detto che più di uno e mezzo non si poteva fare e tu non lo noti
amore mi fai vedere una cosa?
(cosa?) una cosa sul tuo telefono
(no) hai qualcosa da nascondere? (non ho nulla ma..) allora dammi sto telefono
(no, non te lo do) perché (è una questione di rispetto, di privacy, di fiducia) dammi questo telefono subito
Fiducia un par de cojoni se permetti eh
quando ce vo ce vo scusami eh
che poi chi l'ha detto chemi fido di te cioè se ti chiedo il telefono evidentemente é perché ho qualche dubbio se tu non me lo dai
è palese che non mi devo fidare di te perché mi stai mettendo perché mi nascondi qualcosa
siete tutte uguali tutte uguali quando fai così lo sai chi sembri? sai chi sembri? la mia ex
allora mettiamo le cose in chiaro una volta per tutte
innanzitutto non sono io che mi comporto come lei ma è lei che si comporta come me e poi caro mio di come si
comportava di cosa mangiava e di come si pettinava la tua ex non gliene frega niente a nessuno
così, giusto perché tu lo sappia.
amore questa sera guido io... (ah ah, non la mia macchina) ma perché noo
(perché assolutamente no te lo spiego brevemente proprio allora voi donne)
(sapete cucinare, sapete stirare, sapete pulire.)
(guidare è una cosa da uomini)
(dammi ste chiavi, subito)
Ma vergognatevi uomini anni e anni di lotta per la parità dei sessi e ancora ve ne uscite con questi luoghi comuni del cavolo le donne non sanno guidare
le donne non sono abbastanza forti, a belli noi sanguiniamo una volta al mese e non moriamo mai, noi portiamo al mondo la vita
e voi ancora che parlate eh, guardate che é il 2018 e noi donne siamo un passo più avanti... girl power.
Eccoci giunti alla fine del video mi sono divertita tantissimo a farlo perché ha sfogato tutta la mia rabbia repressa verso gli uomini
no, scherzi a parte mi raccomando donne fate vedere questo video a tutti gli uomini che conoscete perché bisogna diffondere il verbo, perché gli uomini devono
sapere una volta per tutte le frasi da evitare se non vogliono far scoppiare la terza guerra mondiale. fatemi saper con un bel commentino qua sotto
quale di queste frasi è quella proprio che odiate di piú quella che proprio non vi devono dire che vi fa uscire fuori di testa
se non l'avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale e
attivate la campanella che trovate vicino al tasto d'iscrizione ma soprattutto seguitemi subito su tutti gli altri social facebook instagram
e musically vi mando un bacione e spero tanto che il video vi sia piaciuto.